ted thanks for that 11 days left in 2021
and the countdown is on for the new year
down is on all right las vegas has a
star-studded lineup to help ring in
20-22 both on and off the strip from
katy perry to vanilla ice you can bet
the celebration will be hot
the countdown is on to ring in 2022 and
las vegas is ready
usher will be dancing the night away to
his popular songs as he wraps up his
coliseum residency on january 1st
a few feet away maroon 5 promises moves
like jagger at the cosmopolitan tickets
starting at 50 bucks
and the lazy song won't be a reflection
to bruno mars style as the countdown
begins he will have fans dancing to his
uptown funk at park mgm tickets are hot
and will set you back a few hundred
bucks act fast because they are selling
out fast
[Music]
mizzo chainsmokers and rick ross also
saying goodbye to 2021 here in town
but not all the fun is along the strip
vanilla ice bobby brown and even the
village people are just some of the
star-studded lineup to get people moving
and grooving to an 80s and 90s dance
party at the fremont street experience
early bird tickets start at 35 dollars
if you're 21 and over kristen chenoweth
is performing at the smith center as she
performs popular hits and songs from her
new album happiness is christmas tickets
start at 45
and finally katy perry also celebrating
in town she will be launching her
resorts world residency play at the new
5 000 seat theater fans can also expect
to roar at midnight when las vegas will
showcase its own fireworks spectacular
to welcome 2022.
so many amazing performers will welcome
2022 here in las vegas so we checked out
some of these events and of course
tickets are still available they start
from about 35 dollars and remember the
midnight fireworks show is free you
can't beat that some pretty pricey ones
the bruno mars ones are expensive very
very good it's a great show
we've also got some pretty big new
year's eve plans for right here at
channel 8. that's right good day anchor
heather mills has all the details
[Music]
you can watch the best new year's party
of the year right here on channel 8 with
countdown to 2022 we'll bring you
celebrations and fireworks from every
time zone hosted by comedian michael yo
in fandango's nikki novak and featuring
an exclusive concert from country star
scottie mccreery we'll be live from
resorts world and all over las vegas
with zoe bowie live from the west gate
las vegas and performances by blue man
group and cirque du soleil the fun
starts at 8 58 so you don't miss the
ball drop in times square
well during that special we'll be
raising money for food banks across the
country with the super bowl of caring
now this qr code links to the donation
side any money you donate will stay
right here in las vegas